I know there must be many thoughts going
through your mind right now
is this the right place for me do I
belong here let me assure you that we
see something in you something you may
not even see yourself even if you do
have X-ray vision
congratulations and welcome to Good
olken University
it's like a big fiery sea cucumber
Golden Boy Jordan Andre they're going
all the way they could save thousands of
people I was coming up with your
superhero name on here
[Music]
bloody Marie that's terrible okay
coagula even worse
I get a [__]
[Music]
ing
there's some weird [__] going on
nobody I don't say we've never heard
about this
this is way bigger than us we need to
make this right this is your shot at
real power
remember no tiny action heroes [__] get
it got it good okay Jesus
digging for the truth is a rush this is
just a tiny bit [__] isn't it don't
answer that it's [__] rhetorically
just a matter of time before they find
out about everything else we're doing if
the wood is exposed we all have a big
potentially fatal problem
s
you're [__] up I'm [__] up
the one thing that is really apparent
now is that is that we are all [__] up
thank you